hey you guys doing another
movie review got a weird one today
like that's anything new you know how i
roll but you know what i mean this is a
movie that i've been wanting to see for
a really really long time and i was very
excited that
uh uk shutter had it i kept seeing it
turn up on you know best movies of
the last 10 years whatever it came out
in 2018
and it's called possum this is a british
film
it's the feature film debut of matthew
holness who i guess
is better known as a comedian like he's
kind of
better known for his comedy roles but he
was also a short story writer and indeed
this movie possum is based on a short
story that he wrote for an anthology
i think was called tales of the uncanny
or something like that
uh the the movie's been changed somewhat
from the short story obviously
but um but he actually did adapt it from
his own storage
short story so he wrote and directed uh
this film now i'm going to tell you
from the outset this is one of those
movies
because you know how i am and it's like
i i really dig
like this really creepy weird unsettling
arty farty type of horror movies and i
know a lot of people don't
you know don't like those now if you
don't like movies like that
if you kind of like more you know gore
films or more action-packed kind of
stuff you will probably hate this
i'm just going to tell you that right
now but i really really dug it this
movie
just the imagery in it was just so so
creepy and like just so unsettling it's
just like really well done but anyway
okay so
matthew wholeness write and directed
this movie which was based on a short
story that he wrote a few years ago
now what the plot of it is is that
there's a dude
named philip and he's played by sean
harris
who i immediately recognized because he
played uh ian curtis from joy division
in 24-hour party people uh several years
ago which is also an awesome movie it's
not a horror movie obviously but
it's about joy division and happy
mondays so you know go check that out if
you're into that kind of music
uh and it also stars alan armstrong as
his creepy
ass uncle and those are kind of there's
a couple of other minor
parts in it but those are pretty much
the only two characters
now matthew holness the writer director
he said he's always been fascinated with
horror he loves really
old school horror and he's particularly
into the look
of silent films german expression of
silent films in particular
so he was curious to see if in his first
film he could do
something approximating a silent film
but in the modern day now this is not a
silent film there is dialogue in it but
there's not
a lot of dialogue in it so so the way
that it it's kind of like
shot the way a silent movie would be
shot but there is
some talking in it but not much um a lot
of it is just kind of like the
cinematography and the visuals
and everything like that it's just it
was filmed um in and around like norfolk
i think
and it's weird because they shot it like
in all these abandoned
buildings and these big empty fields and
these big empty like riverbanks and
stuff like that so it almost
has a weird like post-apocalyptic
kind of look to it it's really really
and it's and it just seems like very
very cold and distant
this isn't right i would call it a
character study
but it's one where you don't really
get into the heads of the characters all
that much
just because i don't know it's just it's
a very off-putting film but i don't mean
that
in a negative way if that makes any
sense it's just really but you it's one
of those ones that you just kind of have
to let yourself
one you have to be in the mood for it
because it's pretty like bleak
and depressing it's one of those kind of
movies um you know it's all just about
trauma and
just creepy like nightmarish kind of
imagery
no not really any jump scares i think
there might be one
but most of it is just kind of like this
just really
unnerving kind of dread [ __ ] that's
going on all the time
but it's just like this really cold
empty
you know landscape and you know these
just these
depressed characters like walking
through it so like i said if that sounds
like something you're not gonna like
then you'll probably hate this
but i don't know i really really liked
it so sean harris plays phillip
now he returns to his hometown
he has been somewhere unspecified uh and
he has lost his job
for some unspecified reason they kind of
imply
that maybe it had something to do with
pedophilia but you don't really know
it's like you don't really know if the
movie's just trying to make you think
that because of what happens later on
um you know so if they're trying to like
set it up you know it's so they don't
really say like why he lost his job
right
so he comes back to i mean he's a
puppeteer i mean i can say that maybe
the reason that he lost his job is if
he's using the puppet which is called
possum
if that's the puppet that he was using
to be a puppeteer then
and if he was doing it at like
children's parties and stuff then yeah i
can see why he probably
wouldn't even have anything to do with
pedophilia which is everyone creepy that
[ __ ] puppet is
because the puppet is they kind of only
give you glimpses of it like throughout
the
film you do get to see it toward the end
but it's basically like
a big okay so it has like a mannequin
head
sort of but it like looks like his head
but then the eyes in it are kind of like
the sort of creepily uncanny realistic
eyes that they put in like cadavers and
[ __ ]
so it has that for a head and then the
rest of its body is like a big
giant spider body like it has these big
spikes like big huge spider legs and
it's probably like i don't know it's
probably like
two or three feet wide so it's this big
giant it's really
it's a great great puppet design it's
just so
creepy i think in the original short
story
possum the puppet was built from like
parts of roadkill like a frankenstein's
monster type of
uh type of scenario but they thought
maybe for the movie that would be like a
little too much so they wanted something
that was like
creepy but not necessarily like gross or
you know too cliched so they came up
with this and they
man they knocked that out of the park
didn't they because this is like a
creepy house like a puppet so his puppet
possum
he's come back after getting fired from
his puppeteer job for whatever reason
um he comes back to his hometown and
one of the things that he wants to do is
destroy
this puppet now the puppet
obviously it represents something
you could say that it represents uh the
past traumas that he suffered
you could even say that it represents i
thought at first that it's
they were sort of saying look it
represents like the dark side of his
personality or something like that
i don't know i think maybe it just
represents him
as a because he's the one that made it
and it does look like him
so i think it does actually sort of
represent his identity to some degree i
guess is what they're uh
shooting for with that so when he comes
back to the town
he's hanging out with his creepy [ __ ]
uncle
and his uncle was apparently also a
puppeteer now as i said there's not a
lot of dialogue in it
but you get the sense that at some point
when philip was a child he must have
been
orphaned and there is a mention of a
fire so i guess there was a house fire
like a house burned down and his parents
were killed
and then he ended up living with his
uncle
and there's the relationship between him
and his uncle even though they don't i
mean they have some conversations but
they're very like
stilted and weird i i read somewhere
that i think the
how they got that was that shawn harris
is a
method actor so he when he works on a
film if you don't know what that means
when he does that stanislavski
stanislavski right method where when
he's in a character working on a film
he's that character like all the time
so him and the guy and alan armstrong
who played the uncle
they didn't uh interact with each other
outside of the
shooting so for that specific reason
because they wanted
the relationship between them to be so
uh
stilted and uncomfortable which indeed
it is because this
the uncle is like super creepy morris is
his name morris or maurice it's spelled
maurice but
i know some in the uk some sometimes
they pronounce it morris and he
pronounces it morris in the movie so
he's basically wandering around
trying to get rid of this puppet but it
seems as though
the puppet keeps returning like he'll
take it somewhere and leave it
like he he has it like in a you know
sort of a leather looks like kind of
like a bowling bag or something like
that
and he has it all in there and then
he'll leave it somewhere but then he'll
wake up
in his room the next day and it's like
hanging on the wall or it's like laying
in the bed looking at him
um one time he puts it in a barrel and
burns it and yet
still it comes back like he'll take it
out to a parking lot and just like tear
it all up
and but it so it seems like it keeps
coming back now another thing too that's
going on
uh at the same time is that
right at the beginning of the movie when
philip is coming home
on the train he's sitting by himself
and he sees all of these four school
boys like over on the other end of the
train car
and he's looking at one of the kids
who's drawing in a book and he sort of
interacts with him he's like oh hey what
are you drawing and then this teenage
kid i mean as most teenage kids
would was just kind of like yo like you
know whatever creep
you know what i mean because shawn
harris in this looks very
weird i've seen him in other roles i
mean he is like a normal looking dude
but in this
it seems like they wanted him to look i
mean he is
his face like this frown is just kind of
like pulled down like
you know the corners of his mouth are
like way down here so he looks really
creepy and then he walks like in a
really creepy like awkward
sort of way so this kid is
understandably freaked out and just like
doesn't talk to him and everything like
that now later on in the movie
like you know a little bit later that
kid
goes missing so the whole time you're
kind of led to believe
that philip may be responsible for this
boy's
disappearance or it could be that
he you know the one thing i was thinking
was that either possum
the puppet is alive and is going and
doing this stuff
you know because he seems to like black
out like i said like he'll go and
destroy the puppet and then he'll
go to sleep or pass out or something and
then he'll wake up and then the puppet
will be back
so i thought that they were trying to
set up you know that he was blacking out
that he was going and doing these things
without being aware of it it's almost
kind of like possum was like his
alter ego sort of and they really do a
good job of setting that up
i don't really want to spoil the ending
but it's not necessarily what you think
it is
you know what i mean so but i really do
like the way they do that because as i
said
they never tell you why he got fired
from his job why he's back in town like
what happened
like you get little hints and stuff of
what happened in the past
um and other people in the town seem to
know him because you know he'll be
walking around and like some
kids or like there's a couple moms and
they'll look over there and be like hey
that [ __ ] creep over there you know
what i mean
so he kind of has a reputation but you
don't know
if it's just if it's because he did
something
or just because he's a creepy weirdo
because he is a creepy weirdo
but you don't actually know if he did
anything until
later on in the movie when it almost it
it almost pulls a kind of reversal
on you which i thought was a really
interesting uh
thing to do because i wasn't sure
i wasn't sure where it was going like it
like i said it seemed to set it up
that you thought that philip was
responsible for that boy being missing
but that he wasn't aware of it like that
possum was
not alive but was a representation of
this evil inside him and he wasn't you
know what i mean it was almost kind of
like a jekyll and hyde type of situation
um and that's not exactly what's going
on but i think it's really interesting
how they
how they did that but yeah so this like
i said if you're not
into arty farty horror if you're not
into you know slow burn kind of [ __ ] i
feel like
if you liked this gave me okay so this
gave me
an eraserhead vibe it gave me a begotten
type of vibe not quite as abstract as
that
but a similar kind of spirit it does
have
a narrative thruster it does have a plot
um it does have a resolution
but there's not a lot of i mean a lot of
it is just
phillip wandering through these bleak
landscapes there's all kind of like he
didn't like these nightmarish images
like possum turning up at various places
and like i said that is a [ __ ] creepy
creepy looking puppet and the best
scenes in this are the ones with the
puppet where he's where like the legs
will come around the corner and then the
little face comes around i mean it's
like [ __ ] super creepy
it's really really well done and it's
i'm just saying you don't need
blood and gory you don't need jump
scares you don't need anything like that
you just just something as simple as
that creepy [ __ ] puppet just putting
its little spider legs and i'm not even
scared of spiders honestly but it's like
just putting these little creepy spider
legs like around a [ __ ] door frame or
something like that creepy
as [ __ ] and like you know and he'll wake
up and it'll be like staring at him and
[ __ ] like that it's [ __ ] creepy but
yeah so like the cinematography it's
just all very
you know everything is abandoned and
shitty looking and
dingy looking and just cold and grim
and it's just it really like takes you
somewhere you know what i mean the score
is great i just i loved it i mean i
really really thought it was
very very good but as i said this is
gonna be one that's gonna be real real
divisive
and i have seen a lot of people who
thought it was like boring or you know
oh nothing happens in it
or something like that and like i got
that i see that um it's not a long movie
it's only 85 minutes
um but like i said a lot of it you
really have to invest yourself
into the atmosphere of it
and of listening to the little bit of
dialogue there is like kind of trying to
read between the lines of it a little
bit because i think there's a lot more
going on behind the conversations than
uh it appears on the surface and as i
said i'm not going to spoil the ending
but
the ending it actually gets pretty
horrific toward the end particularly you
know for
survivors of child abuse um so you know
just a heads up if you don't really want
to see that because the
final scene is you know the last the
last bit is kind of rough to watch
but uh you know it's not gory or
anything like that
it's just like a just a creepy
atmospheric like a mood piece
um with just some great acting
performances great cinematography it's
just a really really well
put together film and if you're into
just the art of film and just the art
and just
and just something that's like real
unsettling like that like i said if you
really like silent movies
you know stuff like the witch or you
know it gave me a little bit of a
babadook kind of vibe as well
just you know because he had like a book
where with creepy drawings and whatnot
um so if that sounds like something that
would be your cup of tea
then you would probably really really
dig this like i said it's called possum
it came out in 2018.
uh check out the poster i love the
[ __ ] poster it's just like this stark
white bed with possum coming out of the
bag like with his little legs they don't
show its face or anything like that they
just kind of show the spider legs coming
out it's just really
stark and it's like really well done but
yeah you know definitely check this out
i saw it on uk
shutter i think you can watch it on vudu
if i'm not mistaken at least as of this
recording
if that sounds like something you would
dig then definitely check it out because
it's really cool that um matthew
wholeness he's trying to
like a lot of comedians do i guess
because comedy and horror go so well
together
and he's kind of trying to even though
he kind of made his name doing comedy
you know he's like i've always been into
horror and i really particularly like um
oh another movie that he uh cited as
inspiration for this was uh martin the
george marrow film and matter of fact i
think he wanted john amplis the guy that
played martin
in the original movie from the 70s to uh
to be in this movie initially but i
guess it didn't work out
but yeah so it has kind of that kind of
vibe to it as well but yeah so
this is his first film and um you know
i'm really looking forward to seeing
what else he comes up with in the horror
genre
because uh this was a real good one so
that will do it for this
flickers of fear and i will see you guys
on the next one bye